nos dicen que durante cuatro días
registras la cantidad de horas que
duermes cada noche redondea cada vez al
cuarto de hora más cercano y luego aquí
en esta tabla nos muestran los días
diferentes
nos dicen cuántas horas dormimos el
primer día dormimos siete y un cuarto de
horas el día 27 y tres cuartos el día 37
y tres cuartos el día 48 y media horas
luego dice haz una gráfica de línea que
muestre todas las mediciones en la
siguiente recta numérica veamos el
primer día dormiste siete horas y un
cuarto entonces ese es un día donde
dormiste siete y un cuarto siete y un
cuarto está justo entre siete y siete y
medio justo allí muy bien en el segundo
día duermes siete horas y tres cuartos
esto es un cuarto dos cuartos tres
cuartos así que ese es el día 2 el
tercer día también dormiste siete horas
y tres cuartos así que ese es otro día
que duermes siete y tres cuartos de hora
y luego en el día cuatro dormiste ocho
horas y media que es justo allí
así aquí vamos hemos creado una gráfica
de línea que muestra todas las
mediciones un día el primer día dormiste
siete horas y un cuarto hubo dos días
donde dormiste siete y tres cuartos de
hora y hubo un día donde dormiste ocho y
media horas hagamos otro ejemplo andy
corrió muchos kilómetros durante
septiembre ella registró cuánto tiempo
le llevo correr cada kilómetro
redondeado al cuarto de minuto más
cercano en la tabla de abajo podemos
verla aquí mismo en realidad voy a mover
mi ventana un poco para que podamos ver
todo y luego dicen haz una gráfica de
línea que muestre todas las mediciones
en la siguiente recta numérica muy bien
así que tres veces pudo correr un
kilómetro en ocho minutos y tres cuartos
entonces hay tres que son ocho y tres
cuartos noten que si observamos el
espacio entre ocho y nueve hay 1234
intervalos iguales y así tres cuartos
serán tres de estos uno dos tres corrió
un kilómetro en ocho y tres cuartos tres
veces eso es lo que vimos en la tabla
entonces ella hizo esto tres veces
corrió un kilómetro en nueve y un cuarto
de mí
22 veces entonces nueve y un cuarto esto
es un cuarto del camino a diez podemos
ver un cuarto dos cuartos tres cuartos
cuatro cuartos entonces nueve y un
cuarto lo hizo dos veces así que será
uno dos y luego veamos nueve y un medio
lo hizo cuatro veces nueve y un medio
está aquí así que uno dos tres cuatro y
luego ocho y un medio lo hizo una vez
así que son ocho y un medio justo allí
después corrió un kilómetro en nueve
minutos cinco veces nueve minutos por
aquí uno dos tres cuatro cinco y ya
hemos terminado